I just want to finish this thought when
it comes to school choice it is it's so
obvious from any framework from any
framework that this is the right thing
let parents choose where they send their
kids to school don't force kids to stay
stuck in failing school systems now I
don't know why I would have the
expectation that people who think it's
okay to groom and mutilate kids and kill
unborn babies would see that also maybe
parents shouldn't be forced to put their
kids in failing schools but even without
those other two questions that people
end up being tied up with their party's
language on and not examining critically
with the school choice stuff you just
got to think it's whenever they say
things like
you're going to destroy or defund the
public school system what they're
acknowledging is parents would choose
anything besides the public school
system if they had a choice so even
their own arguments against school
choice or arguments for school choice